Speaker 1: So the first part of the problem we're
now experiencing in the country is we still have
Trump running around saying corrosive
and damaging things about our democracy,
and it's a real problem. The reason we
worry about it is because thousands of
people still go to the rallies and the guy still
has millions of followers. And I'm going to play
some clips for you of interviews done with
Trump rally goers on Saturday in Conroe,
Texas. And this is really about a lot of things.
What I'm going to play for you is very disturbing.
If there's kids in the room, you may not want them
to see this stuff. But this is about education.
This is about untreated mental illness. In some
cases, you'll see that it's about the weaponizing
of vulnerable people by politicians. It's about
a lot of different things, but at the very top
of the list, it's about this kind of coalescing
of people with the absolute worst instincts to
allow authoritarian strongmen men, wannabes like
Trump to put in place any vision of the country,
even one where there is no due process. There
is no freedom of the press. So we lack all of
those things under this grand vision of people
like Trump and the people, either because they
don't understand or they're distracted with
other things or because they're mentally ill,
they allow it to go on because if Trump wants
it, it must be OK. Let's just start with this
first clip. I won't even introduce it.
Speaker 2: Do your research on this right
here. The World Economic Forum Klaus Schwab.
This is bigger than Trump. This is bigger than
any of us is bigger than any politician. This
is a global plan to enslave you and your family
and pretty much make you poor and dependent upon a
global government. Something I like to call evil.
It's even bigger than that. No, it's spiritual
warfare. I think it's written about in this book.
It's a really popular book. A lot of people
read it. I think the Bible rival revelation,
right? You can't buy or sell without the mark.
Speaker 1: So is this a religious delusion?
Is this mental illness? If you're
watching, you'll notice a guy with a
sign behind these folks that says mass formations,
psychosis, which is sort of the new meme for them.
It can become very difficult to discern what
is merely a psychotic break and delusional
beliefs and paranoid schizophrenia.
And what is a religious nut and what is
someone who's just been brainwashed? I mean, I'm
not joking about these things. It's very tough.
Here's another one of these.
Speaker 2: Everybody's happy
and everybody's got one goal. And that's for
everybody to love everybody and save our save
our country, live their best lives. I got my fancy
unpopular opinion. I'm a flat-Earthers. So like,
Speaker 4: I just been talking to some people
today telling them why I believe what I believe
it's like. I try to find common ground on because
most people would agree that we don't come from
monkeys and that we didn't Big Bang, right?
Speaker 1: So I can tell you guys, this guy
is definitely this guy definitely didn't Big
Bang. I would. I would. I would concede that.
But this is what do we make of that? Is
this is this a sick person or or what is it?
Speaker 4: If you can find common ground with
people, then you can start building a foundation
of like what truth is, you know? So hey,
Speaker 2: let's go bridge.
Speaker 1: Right? So it's sort of quite a
contrast, right? We didn't come from monkeys.
We didn't Big Bang. Let's find truth. And
let's go, Brandon. Here's another woman
asked about who knows something. She's holding
a huge Trump head. It's like four feet tall.
The size of Trump's that. That's the size
of this Trump had that she's holding.
Speaker 5: So that's what all this is.
Speaker 2: All of it.
Is this your first Trump rally?
Speaker 5: No, sir. I went to Tulsa, Oklahoma,
in April tools, and it was a freedom fest. And
Clay Clark's Reawaken America tour. And it was
about educating people that some of the ideas that
we're going through need to be researched a little
deeper. There's way too much false information.
Speaker 1: That's true. The problem is she's
coming up on the wrong end of it,
Speaker 5: and you need to educate
yourself and help educate yourself on your. Water,
educate yourself on what you put in your body,
and that's a personal choice that they should not
have the right to take that away from us.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. I couldn't agree
more. Well, keep using your voice.
Speaker 1: Keep, keep speaking
whenever I want to know the truth. When I want
to educate myself, when I want to dig deeper,
I go to someone who's holding a four
foot tall cardboard trumpet. I mean,
it's just perfectly natural, guys. Then he goes up
to some kid and you can tell this guy's been been.
Read the Riot Act on fake news. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: All right. What do you think about
the way the media just goes for broke on
their lives? I think that people should stop
listening to the media, right? And watch y'all's
stuff because y'all don't lie about anything,
right? And watch Republican news. I mean, there's
some news networks that are just Democrat,
and they're brainwashing the people, right?
Speaker 1: Just watch Republican news and
right side broadcasting, and then you'll
know the truth. You'll know everything.
Lastly, or no, not lastly, I got a couple more
for you. Here's a woman in a box. She wore a box,
and she really misses Trump's tweets her entire
life used to be wrapped up in Trump's tweets.
Speaker 5: He was kicked off
Twitter. I mean, I miss those tweets.
Speaker 2: Do you? What do you do it
every single day of my life? That's
what I spent doing for five years.
Speaker 1: What a sad life, huh?
Speaker 2: Literally. I mean, it's everything I
did, and I miss him terribly and the people miss
them terribly. That's the sad thing.
Speaker 5: Hear me out again.
Another business idea
Speaker 1: everybody misses
Trump's tweets her entire life for five years
went around Trump's tweets. All right. Now,
I don't know if it goes from funny to scary.
Maybe it wasn't even funny to begin with.
Here's a woman who thinks that Joe Biden was
actually killed two years ago at Guantanamo
Bay and that there is now a fake Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: Why? What? Why are you here to support
Trump? What's your motivation? He's
our real president. Thank you very
much. And what are you basing that on?
Speaker 5: The fact that the election
was stolen and who is our real president, by
the way, is making him the real? Biden was
assassinated getting out in 20 19 March in 2019.
Speaker 1: So, Tony. So listen to the number of
lies. Trump's the real president Trump actually
won the real Biden was assassinated or,
as she says, and assassinated two years ago.
Speaker 2: I agree. I agree with you at the
bar that there's no way the Dominion machines
they've already been proven all over the world
was crooked distributions. But Trump's having 40,
50, 60 thousand people at his rallies before the
presidency or for the election by 50 people. That
includes the people there for security and the
media all together, and he supposedly got more
votes than Obama. So how do you explain that?
Speaker 5: Because the American people know
who were really president and we're fighting
for America and we are going to save this country
and the world. I know that I find it a pedophile,
and then I wanted to see because I know
Speaker 2: he's a pedophile. Our creepy Joe
Speaker 5: Trippi Joseph protocol, did you know
that he had an island and his family has an
island near Epstein Island miles away? I didn't
know his family. It's called Water Island. Yeah,
well, it's
Speaker 2: a family
of three is, I guess, like a call Neverland. Come
on, Michael Jackson. You know, Michael Jackson was
saving the children. They just turned his back.
Speaker 1:
Even that the guy tries to agree, the guy goes,
Yeah, Biden's got a pedophile island. Kind of
like Michael Jackson's Neverland as she goes, No,
no, no, no, no, no. Michael Jackson was not doing
anything wrong. He was saving the kids attention.
Speaker 5: Jackson, I thought for years he was
on the bad side. He's not. He was saving the
children. And when he plays at the inauguration,
when Michael Jackson comes in place for
us, people are going to realize that.
Speaker 1: So she thinks Michael Jackson is alive.
Speaker 2: You think so?
Speaker 5: He had a big cheer. Never
of that big cue saving the children.
Trump helped him asking for help. John F.
Kennedy Jr. escape yacht Princess Diana.
Speaker 1: Sir John F. Kennedy Jr. and Princess
Diana are also alive. How? How is this even? You
know, we're up against the political movement
that's filled with people with no connection
to reality, undiagnosed and certainly untreated
mental illness, at least in some cases. Here's the
last one about a satanic system that we're in
Speaker 2: that is pure evil, good versus
evil. It's not left right Democrat.
Speaker 5: And I believe that to right now,
you know what I'm saying? I'm saying, I
think I think this system that we've got
going on right now is a satanic sister system and
imitator. And let me tell you something I believe
I believe Satan is on his J-O-B man. He is on his
job and we need to be getting on with our job.
We got to take this country back from God, man.
Speaker 2: You got to take this country back,
but Jesus Christ, man. Yeah. Amen. Yes.
Speaker 1: So always, you know, it's really
a unique mix that is not common in other countries
of lack of education. Religiously based delusions,
conspiracies and in some loose sense, mental
illness that can include paranoid schizophrenia
and other things. That's I'm not diagnosing any
particular individual. We're saying the movement
has all of those things
within it. How do you even?
Run against such a movement, that's a
really difficult question to answer. We'll
have some of these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.